hello and welcome to
another episode of not fat man beyond
black man beyond because our boy kevin
smith
is uh is off in the in the bosom of his
origins in new jersey
watching his movies pop up and doing a
podcast with jason muse
leaving me to my own devices uh we are
not at
the scrum and vilni cantina today
because it seemed as if
without kev there was no real reason for
me to drive anywhere
um and also in order to preserve
any sense of of uh i don't know
viral decorum that for my special guest
host
yiti badaki we would just do it on zoom
like you know people are supposed to do
um
also she is in the desert preparing for
a zombie apocalypse
i am preparing for well who isn't though
who isn't right it feels like we're at
the time where uh
every every other plague
locusts murder hornets i mean you know
like evil mosquitoes fires earthquakes
droughts hurricanes i feel as if we are
in
the third act of like a biblical
apocalypse movie pretty much but i also
would want to give that writer notes
and say you know maybe you don't want to
be so heavy-handed too much
like maybe yeah a little a little uh
a letter touch i think would we we get
it ease off it
yeah is it possible to have too many
stakes because i feel like we kind of do
many stakes uh i think 2020 is the prime
example
of too many stakes yeah we could all use
a rewrite on this year
um but i am so glad that you were able
to make some time
uh to hang out with me tonight because
we've wanted to do this for a long time
um at least a year i think maybe more
we've been trying to figure out like you
are often
in in the hinterlands of canada um
you know shooting american gods and we
were here and then kevin was on tour and
i was like now's the time and you were
like i can maybe make it back this
weekend i don't know
uh and it just didn't work but today we
got it
yeah yeah today we friggin got it so we
did it everybody
i'm so excited i'm so excited i'm also a
little nervous
it's a combination of both don't be
nervous this will be the
easiest thing this is just like you know
a zoom you would always ordinarily do
with a person
right i i figure you're going to get
unedited yet
because mark outstanding
we win um when
did we first meet i was trying to do it
it's so hard to do
um this sort of like um digital
uh you know detective work to figure out
when you met somebody you mostly know
from the internet um
um who the what now the car chase
yes we went out to dinner we were both
invited to dinner by
um sci-fi wire share martinelli who was
in town
and she's like meet me for dinner and i
said okay i'm
happy sure happy to do that and and i
didn't know that she also invited other
people
because she's uh she's also from jersey
and jersey people are rude
um
that's all me yeah uh i also lived in
jersey for a long time and
you know i i have love for jersey and
yet and yet
um but you were at this dinner and we
were at some taqueria
in like west hollywood or something and
and
we were eating eating and then suddenly
and there was drinking
and eating and there was a car chase
like on the news and
that took over like the latter half of
that evening it pretty much took
i mean what else can you focus on when
there's just like this high speed chase
where they ended up going into like a
subway tunnel
remember he was badass like amazing
it was like it was like speed but for
real
where like these dudes like speed meets
the italian job or like is that
music and figures like is this a heist
what do they say why are they in the
subway tunnels in downtown l.a who does
that
yeah who thinks that's a good idea dom
toretto thinks that's a good idea
yeah but i remember that's the first
time we met and then we just kind of
kept on geeking out after that didn't we
i know because i
i always relish finding another geek in
the wild um
and and because not to say that we are
few and far between
but uh but we are few and far between
you know especially sort of geeks of
color and especially geeks of color who
are sort of professionally at work
making geek [ __ ] um it is a relatively
small
club so to find one that you didn't know
was one you're like
where have you been hiding
[Laughter]
um one of my favorite things was was it
last year
san diego comic-con where yes
got to walk the floor and there you were
and you made me
so happy
[Laughter]
and i was just it was one of those
because i have been for a long time that
that was
the last comic con um would have was
this would have been my 20th comic con
like in a row
wow and uh and so i've gotten to the
point where i visit the floor
sort of like twice a convention over
those five days it's like the first day
that i'm there i'll do like a
get the lay of the land and then the
last day i'm there
i'll do like my last minute shopping and
stuff right
but i just happened to have a signing on
the floor that day
and so i was like you know let me just
walk let me go to artist alley i've been
an artist alley yet i want to see who's
down there
and so i'm like is that your teeth just
kind of tooling around
like chilling just chilling as you do
hanging out
you know i've been putting comic con man
what else am i supposed to do
and i was there again thanks to share
morton eddie her name's coming up
but yeah the sci-fi um instagram
takeover
sci-fi wire or sci-fi fan girls that's
right that's right so guys i found you
on the floor and then we just walked
around for like an hour
and you took over an instagram account
and we found a bunch of cosplayers that
were awesome i remember we found like
the us
family they were so good who was just
badass and frightening
yeah boombox too playing the music
they did they did which was amazing but
like that's that's my favorite
experience of comic con
is walking around and having interesting
amazing things happen
without plan like because i've planned
to see people at comic con and those
plans fall through
um it feels like it's a place that
rewards happenstance
in the best way um and that was super
fun so yeah
yeah yeah yay us for letting the random
fate
uh thrust us together on the comic-con
floor
um but tell tell the people who
might not know the the long and
wonderful
itty-bitty story um all the way from the
beginning
let's go all the way back like let's go
let's go let's go to the motherland
well we are going to the motherland you
know that
you also know my name means mother is
back right
i do yeah which is awesome
it's uh yeah cause i was born a year
after my grandmother died
um so basically i'm my grandmother well
exactly we are all the ancestors are
coming through us at all times
my name doesn't mean very much it means
friggin awesome well i know this i i
i didn't see that in the baby book um
it's like which one of these names being
freaking awesome oh my
god mark and bruno yeah yeah i think
literally just means to note
[Laughter]
interesting uh but yeah it started in
the motherland
it started with um i was tell
talk about stories by the fire you know
with the elders
i have a lot of family i don't know if
you know this i have
a lot of family how much is a lot of
family
like i think my granddad had maybe
around 10 wives or something oh damn
yeah on average they all had like
maybe around 10 kids each these are not
exact numbers
[Laughter]
we're rounding up but that's the thing
like i'm
always running into family all around
the world and i
actually think there's a family com
connect with me
on uh um lovecraft
wow yeah it's uh it's really interesting
we found that out running into each
other at an audition
i still remember we were there and she's
like yeah i just saw your family at the
and yeah um but i digress you digress
so the beginning is in nigeria yes in
nigeria
stories by the fires where storytelling
became a huge thing for me
um if if you ever get the chance to to
listen to elder nigeria's tells
nigerians tell school it's it's an
experience it really is
and you know it wasn't until recently i
realized that i had never
that i hadn't actually seen back to the
future too
when i thought i did because
it was a cousin who had traveled and
seen the movie
and was telling all of us and it was so
wonderfully done that i remember
watching the movie i'm like no that
doesn't happen there
the oral tradition the oral tradition
right
but uh yeah i was uh born there but then
from
three to six i spent that time in
england
went back to nigeria until i was 12.
um things uh there was a quite a bit of
unrest at that time
and which i've kind of jokingly but not
um said you know the way things have
been happening here
i was joking to someone the other day
i'm like i feel like kind of
i've been transported back to nigeria
with the rolling brownouts and the
you know it's uh yeah the whole surreal
yeah i believe it i believe it um i i'm
so nigerian to england back to nigeria
then to the states
yeah then to the states um from 12 to
16.
and i started college at 16. oh you're
so smart
not really
[Laughter]
i'm really good at what do they call it
cramming
ah that would help with the learning the
lines real quick
yeah that kind of came in the
in the picture there um but that took me
to montreal
okay undergraduate and
that's where i continue to be able to
sneak in some theater
until it became my major
is that mcgill university yale
university
it is literally the only college i know
in canada
no actually because uh i mean chatter
helps but uh
another a tv writer friend of mine john
rogers is a graduate from mcgill
um in physics like he's got one of the
biggest brains i've ever met and then he
went into tv writing i'm assuming for
the money
i don't know what physicists make but um
yeah mcgill is a big science school but
here does i know a lot of people who
went to mcgill did the science
majors and then they're here in l.a
writing
it's it's fascinating again it must be
the money like i i remember seeing a
news story about a
football player plays for the kansas
city chiefs i think laurent duvernay
tardif
um who is also a medical doctor who
graduated from mcgill university and i'm
like that but
come on why isn't the any canadian i
ever hear that went to college
went to that college we went to mcgill
i remember hanging out the shatner
building a lot which
technically we weren't supposed to call
it the shatner building but
like you know yeah oh come on yeah who
was not going to call it that
did it have a very nice dupe is that why
it's called the
chat i don't remember it's like the
student building and i don't remember
why it's you know people first started
calling it that
i remember why they said officially we
shouldn't because it wasn't you know
like something he had
had dedicated right somebody else paid a
lot of money for that building that
wasn't william shack
but we all called it the shatner
building because oh well good for you
bill
[Laughter]
um then after that was um auditioning
for
grad schools um still remember that trip
to new york
me and my roommate went down we had no
money so it's like
a bag of bagels we bought for the
weekend and
uh then the hotel if you wanted light in
the bathroom you had to
unscrew the light bulb
[Laughter]
plus you also didn't want to look too
closely at what was happening in the
lobby
you know it was yeah one of those
yeah but that got me into um illinois
state university
outstanding i i feel like
i remember i went to i went to a doctor
at a doctor's dorm the other day
and uh one was like where are you from
your cell phone number it's like where's
that area goes i go to new jersey
she says oh you don't have a new jersey
you don't have an east coast accident i
was like well
here's the thing my mother was born in
the states my father was born in haiti
and i grew up in new york
and so all of those strong accents
collided
and have resulted in just neutrality you
just can't gather out
they just all cancel each other out and
so i wonder if a lot of your
international kind of hopscotching um
leaves you with a a timber and a sound
that doesn't betray
yeah um and i think yep that has a lot
to do with it and plus i
heard a lot of different dialects um
elementary school um and
yeah it's usually voice coaches and
stuff that
can tell immediately that i'm not
they're like
you have no regionalism
very transatlantic yeah
um so when when did your uh when did
your
nerdery begin to to to evince itself you
know like
like a mutant in the x-men was it like
14 years old along with puberty was it
before then was it after then
i mean i guess i'm that rare well not
rare but i'm an early mutant then
is pretty much from the get-go um
i mean those stories by the fire yes
there's a lot of
you know great uh god stories and things
like that
there mythology and then i loved norse
mythology and greek mythology and
i mean as soon as i could pick up
something to read
um i was looking at that stuff and i was
reading a lot of stuff that i probably
shouldn't have at like six years old oh
boy yeah i remember
but my uncle was a professor and i
remember
going to his place and he had the i
think it was the mom's christian
anderson
um uh the fairy tales was it honks
um it's the ones where they're all just
really bloody
oh grims fairy tales rims there we go
and everyone died and people's feet were
cut off
and i just remember returning it with
like this look on my face like that was
not what i was expecting
um do you have more you have more though
um then from there it's like things like
ray bradbury you know
stephen king isaac asimov
as far back as i can remember those
things all really appealed to me
um and then as far as tv i remember when
we got
satellite television and
there was star trek next generation
and that i mean you know my whole world
view
is based off of that it's a fair
way to build a world view i mean if you
have to choose a fictional
uh system of government and ethos and
morality like next gen is not a bad way
to go
i mean it was uh highly influential
and you know my first crushes theta
and captain picard data is your first
crush
and captain picard but i was talking to
someone yesterday
and i just realized i was yesterday
years old
when i realized i also was crushing on
diana troy the whole
time i feel like everybody was kind of
crushing on deanna troy
a lot um yeah yeah
yeah i feel like there's there's the
like are you a crusher guy
or are you a troy guy oh they're all
i mean they're all incredible but it was
a lot like the uh
like um gilligan's island it's like are
you a ginger or a marianne person
are you uh are you a troy or a crusher
person
oh man now this that whole show although
i think
2020 is also very reminiscent of
the episode was it the visitor
do you remember that one where the guy
um where they ended up in a whole other
i don't know was it dimension or
something because they'd had
a traveler oh the traveler maybe
oh yes the traveler sends them to the
far reaches of the universe
that everybody thinks just manifests
20 20. yeah yeah
i i've taken some weird odd solace in
the fact that star trek predicted how
awful the 21st century was going to be
because on more than one occasion when
people are time traveling they're like
well
what what this is 2025. why is it so
awful it's like yeah we don't talk much
about this
yeah world war iii is about to happen
again it's uh this is a garbage fire
yeah yeah but then the great news is
that it all turns around
it does right and we find a common
humanity
we do and we all wear clothes with no
pockets because we don't need money or
identification
and we're all just unitard knit all over
the place yeah
it's all about the unitard that's how
you know you're in the future
like how else do you how else do you
gauge whether or not you're actually in
the future
pretty much it's unitard or unitard plus
vest if you're like a heavier older dude
true well you know unicorn unit you know
it's really a whole other thing that's
all another thing
yeah um star trek uh definitely
that was um that influenced me and then
that that was around the time too though
we started watching
uh quantum leap yeah
and uh which i i i still say
if it was on now it would have all the
awards
i i feel like if it was on now i was i
saw somebody on twitter
when when the news came out that um the
streaming
ratings and now that's a thing we get we
haven't we didn't we used to be able to
know
how anything was performing on streaming
but netflix decided all right let's
[ __ ] it let's release some information
and lucifer was like the number one show
on streaming
and it's like remember when um we used
to make shows like this
where it's just it's kind of episodic
it's a case of the week
it's kind of like good-natured fun
detective
bantery sexy funny all of those things
were kind of tied together by a loose
mythological thread but
you could drop in on any episode of
lucifer and know exactly what's
happening
remember we used to do that we abandoned
it for this like weird bbc model of like
eight episode
densely sort of mythological and and
narrative and
and uh which are great like i i love
that
but we also used to do that thing and
that thing is actually really rewarding
and really comforting and really
you know um it uh it rewards continual
viewing and
quantum leap was that was the every week
this dude's gonna say and beckett's
gonna jump into a new body and we're
gonna have an adventure and he's gonna
solve a problem
and then bam he's off to the next thing
also he can leap his way home
like it's such a crystal pure premise
and and and loaded with comedy and
romance and drama
and all of those things but it seems
like we've
abandoned making that kind of show which
is a little sad
it is but you know hopefully everything
does kind of come around in a cycle
i know i'm hoping that like the
the news of things like lucifer doing
very very
very well we'll remind people oh
remember we used to do that like and
people liked it
and if we kept doing it they'd watch it
figures huh yeah yeah yeah
even wisdom conventional wisdom is also
cyclical which is both
sad and um evident
don't even don't even get me started oh
no
i did fair enough and i think
the first time i the first time i did
meet you
was before that um
dinner with cher because it must have
been three or four comic-cons ago
i was at a party that stars through um
for both ash then the evil ash versus
evil dead
yes that was our first year and american
gods
and i've known neil gaiman for a while
um from a from a former life as a
journalist
and a comics nut and uh the biggest
sandman fan like in the world
and uh and so i i met him years and
years and years ago and so now every now
and again i
bumped into him out in in the ether and
it's always like this lovely little mark
how
are you tell me how's everything going
like let me show you pictures of my kid
um but then he just started like
introducing me to
people and i was like i want to meet ian
mcshane he's like everybody wants to
meet him
i want him to read me things just say
things in his voice a lot
i mean just hearing your name in his
voice
he was wearing like some seersucker suit
that only like a dandy english jet could
pull off
yeah um and he introduced me to you and
you know you're like oh hey
and then you bounce off because you're
fabulous
this had nothing to do with any kind of
fabulous
you know after you had met me for over
five minutes that i am the biggest dork
in the world
but it was really because that was that
was like my first big
you know event the first time i'd
come to comic-con for one uh the first
time
coming to something as a series regular
um
it was just a whirlwind so there are
moments i didn't remember my own last
name
so i don't even know how i got here i
don't know who i met here
i don't know it all
just disappeared so yeah that that was
yeah it was a whirlwind i totally
believe it
um what was what was it like the first
time you met
neil gaiman because i feel like you know
for nerds that is a bit of like am i
sitting down with
santa claus you bring me all the things
that i like
all the things all the things and here's
the thing
like neil is such a repository of
information
you know and first off he has the most
incredible storytelling voice ever
so as soon as you start speaking on
something you automatically lean in and
you're like yeah oh okay
got it um and then there's usually some
incredible history behind
whatever it is and it's just but
see i can speak like that now
the first time i met him um i still say
he must have thought i was an
absolute weirdo because all i could do
was just kind of
like shake his hand and nod my head and
then scurry off
i couldn't even speak um
gosh i was so embarrassed about that for
so long um
but then over time you know it was like
i started culminating uh words
i'm gonna get a sentence one of these
days buddy i'm gonna put together a
whole sentence
one of these days maybe even a paragraph
what
just you wait it's gonna be great but
yeah
it was mind-blowing it was mind-blowing
meeting him yeah
yeah i when i was a when i was a
journalist dc comics used to do this
thing
um which i don't think they do anymore
um which was
we're gonna have a bunch of talent uh in
town i was in manhattan at the time
we're gonna have a bunch of talent in
town for some story summit or a meeting
or whatever
and so we're going to uh we're gonna
throw a dinner or a cocktails or
whatever
and we'll invite some members of the
press and we'll we'll you know have like
these three or four
big ass freaking giant creators and
we'll all just go out and hang out and
it'll be fun it'll be like kind of
intimate like seven or eight people
total
and so one night it was like me
and a couple of other people that i
worked with at ew
who were nerds and neil gaiman um
david masicelli frank miller and i think
bilson kevich
um i think there might have been one
more
but i can't remember who that would have
been but it's [ __ ]
bonkers like i'm sitting like just
drinking with again that's the date of
the dark knight returns
that's new gaming and uh and neil was
i think endless nights um the sort of
like one of the first follow-ups that he
did of coming back to sandman was just
coming out in hardcover
and uh and so he he's like do you want a
copy he's like yeah sure so let me sign
it for you and then he takes the book
and he starts signing and he starts
sketching
he's like every writer should know how
to sketch at least one character in
their comics so that when you're doing a
signing you can like make it real and so
he draws me as sandman
you're so awesome i want you to adopt me
wouldn't it be great
i mean i love my parents but this would
be super awesome no
that would be the best yeah
and he i mean he's so great like that
like he will always make you know
he will always make time for autographs
he'll always make time to
chat with people um yeah i mean i
i think it's something to do with he is
also a fan
and has been a fan and understands what
that
energy is like and and i mean i and i
i respond to that and i recognize that
and kevin smith also that idea of like i
used to grow up
loving stuff like this and idolizing
people who made this stuff and so if
somebody
you know feels that way about anything
i've created then it's
like i owe you more than you owe me
you know what i mean and like i will
make time
and i've seen that dude like trying to
hustle through an airport
like he'll stop for every picture you
know and he'll take time
like every tsa guy every whatever it's
like hey man you want a picture yeah for
sure let's get come on in we'll do this
you mean science i'm happy to sign it no
problem whatever you need
and just that level of understanding
what it feels like to be on the other
side
of that equation and always respecting
the the the sort of desire and
willingness to make an ass out of
yourself to tell somebody that you like
that you like them
um and it's it's something to not look
sideways at something to never take for
granted and i feel like neil
is that kind of person also
absolutely and you know who else is to
um made me feel like that was
brian and um because i remember
you know you're talking about those big
fancy dinners
first year there's a big fancy dinner
with big
you know executives you know all these
suits and people that could probably
fire you yesterday if they
you know felt there was a reason to now
look if that's
something that actually would happen who
knows but that's what you know
early yeti was thinking
and i remember sitting down at that
dinner first off thinking how am i gonna
like take a bite of anything um
and uh but brian has seated me right
next to him
and then he starts to email star trek
and then i was able to breathe
and we just nerd it out all night oh
that's awesome
um it made me feel so much at home so
yeah i do gravitate to well i mean
there's you
oh yeah we gravitate to people who are
awesome i i feel like
there's there's something the lingua
franca of nerd you know is this sort of
like universal language that if you can
speak it
and if you're gonna recognize it in
somebody else at the very least you know
you have one thing in common
yeah which is like no no we can we we
can dirt out over something
yeah um and it it definitely greases the
wheels and calms the nerves
and you're just like oh no you're just
like i am you've also spent way too much
time
reading way too late at night by the
light of a single bulb
um because you can't put this book down
or you've also been
some show you know over a weekend that
you totally didn't have time for but you
did it anyway
like we we have those impulses and we
can recognize
game recognizes game right and
that's what it is third game recognizes
every game recognizes nerd game and it's
and it's never or at least it shouldn't
be
exclusionary like it should be welcoming
it's like hey dude have you seen this
this is awesome
i haven't seen that should i yeah you
should watch that like it's
it's about that sharing enthusiasm i
love about nerds and geeks and you know
everyone in general it's it's because
it's just people sharing what they love
and giving the permission for someone
else to share what they love and it's
all just like it's just this
love fest um
and and so it's always i that's why i
adore
comic-cons that's why spaces because
it's just a lot of
joy i mean i remember being there to
sign
things and then nettie okorafor shows up
and i had to jump out my seat and just
geek out hard because she's one of my
favorite writers
um and it was just it was this kind of
full circle thing because
then i had to go back and sign for
someone else that was super excited
about it
just it's i i love it i i love being i
would wouldn't change it for anything
that's awesome what are you what are you
geeking out over currently what's what's
on your like oh
i can't miss an episode of this or i
can't i can't put this down
love the binging and stuff well i i
recently
joined uh marvel unlimited um i'm going
through all those comics and you know
who i'm following i'm
like the list right now i'm you know
the one and only storm yes
so that's part of reading and then black
hammer
was what i was reading as well then
watching
i don't know if anybody else is watching
this but okay there are a myriad of
reasons i love it um on netflix
and it's a korean show oh and
okay let me tell you all the reasons
that i love this show please
evangelize preach okay
um for one the obvious sci-fi element
that you know is traveling between
uh parallel worlds
gosh we've seen so many examples of that
in these parallel worlds with
different versions of everybody but
the thing that makes me so happy
is that they do a scene in one episode
so maybe two people meet and there's
only one line
and you see all the action that they do
around that one line and then it moves
on
well in the next episode a writer or
somebody has decided they have not
gotten enough out of this scene
so they go back to that same scene
and then add lines and it's just
i don't know why it blows my mind so
much because they wouldn't
visit it two three times and go up
adding different lines and you're like
wait but last week it was
you know um it makes me
um just unbelievably happy every single
time they do it
like yes we did not get enough mileage
out of that scene we had good actors the
location was fun
let's just do more let's just do more
with it which
i think is kind of interesting too
because then you have
then you have new writers come in and go
you know i really like that scene what i
wish happened was right like do we own
this location can we just keep going
back here over and over and over again
because we will so i finished the whole
thing
you know i didn't sleep a couple of
nights but
went through it absolutely of course i
have to support my girl roomie
so i've been watching uh lovecraft
um and uh let me see there's so
i've also been doing well there was a
while pretty much
weekly that i would get together with a
friend
um over the internet and watch
some geektastic film from the past
oh that sounds fun oh so much fun
cause like you can go back and do things
like buckaroo banzai
and obviously back to the future
rocky horror picture show um
fifth element it's just we go through
and at that point you can pretty much
talk through it because oh yeah i've
that's the key because you can't watch
something you've never watched before
because then you might as well just be
watching alone
um but yeah they're they're i've been
watching
um with a bunch of friends avatar the
last airbender like once it dropped on
netflix it was
is it avatar tuesday yet then let's
let's go
and we would just watch like two or
three at a clip and we'd all
seen it before so it was cool to be able
to just kind of like talk through it and
over it and then everybody be quiet when
something awesome happened and then you
just keep going
and and that it feels very much like
um a way to sustain community at a time
in which community is a little far from
us
you know like and that thing that nerds
love to do which is
let's watch something we all love
together let's all go to the movies
together let's all
you know like and i miss that so much
yeah that sense of community and sharing
what what you love
yeah so we're trying to find ways to do
that
we're trying to find ways to to make our
way through it it's funny the more and
more technology we
get i feel like the more that the
technology is trying to reinvent the
idea of the village so
you know as we have evolved so much
we're still trying to get back
to that place yeah yeah you know and i
think that
the more technology we have the more it
makes me long to not
need to use technology to do it you know
the more i'm on a zoom the more i'm on a
zoom with like 15 people the more i'm
like wouldn't this be better
if we were just like at a table
somewhere
or in a bar somewhere or at somebody's
house in a backyard
and like it's yeah it is it is
highlighting what is absent
while also being a a a less than
replacement yeah and it's i mean
i have panels on it i find i'm still
struggling with because i miss the live
energy
people you know and seeing everyone and
there's something that people uh emit i
think
yeah yeah like i i tuned into some of
the san diego at home
stuff this year um i was able i was
lucky enough to be part of some of the
dc fandom stuff
and they're slowly refining it and
slowly bringing it into
into something that feels like a
worthwhile thing in and of itself
yeah but it always has that feeling of
you know
we'd rather be doing it the other way if
at all possible
we'd rather all be six thousand of us in
a room
you know and and like you said just
feeling that charge and that those waves
of enthusiasm
and the excitement to be in a place to
hear people
that you like talk about something that
you love it's a
it's hard to channel that level of
energy
this way you know especially if it's
only really a one-way broadcast
you know like that's the thing we are
we're fighting it we're getting there
we're getting in there but what are you
um what are you binging what can you
not put down right now um i uh
i'm i'm all in on lovecraft um i feel
like the most recent episode
was um the
i'm not gonna say the best of the bunch
i've seen so far episode five
um which was the the strange case i
think it was called
um or something something but it was
very much like jekyll and hyde it was
very much about
um ruby uh being able to take this magic
potion and become a
a average white woman and the dream of
being an average white woman
for a a you know gorgeous
effervescent black woman you know is its
own like it
it talked a lot about um
the themes of being comfortable in your
own skin
and being one and wanting to be
something more than you are
or having been taught your entire life
that what you are is not
right um and i feel like she
you know felt seen in that voice
she did in ways that like sadly
um were not being seen as herself and
she couldn't
she couldn't keep up that ruse like that
that wasn't a fantasy she could live
with
um you know and then conversely montrose
you know tick's father
you know is a gay man living in a time
in which you could not be
black and gay and and still be
recognized as a man
and so had had just submerged
all of those impulses and desires um
which started to burst at the seams in
violent ways
and so to get to watch him have a moment
where he
feels free baptism
glitter did you know that i did
[Laughter]
the most fabulous baptism ever like okay
i see and i love that they had shangela
there
um yeah there was so much in it
i mean there's so much to unpack um
i found myself deeply
affected um by
everything that was going on i mean we
know repression is a horrible thing i
was also
you know there there's i had some
concerns too for
my for our indigenous and two-spirit
family
previous uh episode as well and seeing
all of the things that um
that montrose uh was having come up to
the surface
because he was not able to be who he was
it was striking it was
unsettling in so many places
um women did a fantastic job oh yeah
fantastic actress uh i think a lot of
people have been sleeping on her
and they shouldn't be they shouldn't be
no she's killing it
she's killing it yeah i mean the the
show for me like every episode
is and clearly it's meant to feel a bit
like an anthology
where every episode is tackling a
different format where it's haunted
house where it's
road movie where it's um
national treasure we're just doing like
treasure hunting indiana jones
this is jekyll and hyde this is like
hiding in in somebody else's skin
um and i feel like the thematically the
show is firing on all cylinders in ways
that occasionally
dramatically it's not um or structurally
it's not
and i don't know if it's interested in
it you know what i mean like there are
some times we're just
oh okay we're in this location now are
we gonna explain how we got here
no okay moving on
you know like the emotional truth of it
is what
seems to be foremost on the producers
minds less the
kind of narrative um strict
you know adherence to to to that kind of
logic
and it took me a couple of episodes to
kind of swing with it that way
but once like oh this is how we're
telling these stories
okay cool there's a lot here that i'm
getting and unpacking which
which makes me fine glossing over
some of those like what oh sure
he's like that happened okay oh fine
okay they were in there in boston and
now they're back in chicago and they we
did in the car somehow also got back and
okay whatever
cool it'll be fine but yeah it was
um there were some moments i i mean
there was some moments that i always
laugh when i say this that were hard to
watch
and the reason i laugh when i say this
is because do you remember
dirty rock when tracy decided that he
wanted to get like the whole
like ego it like and everything
so he decides to make a movie called
hard to watch
get all the awards
so whenever i'm describing anything like
that oh yeah it's going to get all the
awards oh yeah
it's hard to hard to watch
um but yeah there were some some moments
i had to take a breath there
yeah um i had my my big quarantine binge
was the walking dead which i had you
know i started
watching when it aired and i was a
weekly you know adherent to it
and then fell off like i think i moved
cross-country and like dropped out of it
for a little bit
and then they got to a place that they
were hanging out for too long i was like
yeah
whatever i'll get to it later and didn't
and so now i have nothing else to do so
let's watch
ten seasons of the walking dead and so
now i'm all caught up in the walking
dead so now we started uh
fear the walking dead which is good but
frustrating because it's now back at the
beginning when nobody knows anything
about zombies and you as a viewer like
dude they're zombies what the [ __ ]
like did you not watch the walking dead
how do you not know what's happening
you know like zombie fiction i think is
the only fiction in which the characters
don't know
that zombies exist it's like if you like
vampire
stuff everyone knows vampires like
nobody's surprised when somebody gets
like is that guy exaggerated i think
he's a vampire
but nobody believes that zombies exist
in zombie fiction until
they're like guys meanwhile
i'm here with like my zombie escape plan
i mean
yes okay we're gonna get to the news but
first uh i feel like we should compare
um zombie escape strategies okay zombie
escape strategies
first off uh you know as soon as stuff
gets you know starts going down you need
to go somewhere
very isolated yes yes stay
out of the downtowns and the super
populated
areas just don't be in l.a
just yeah or if you are you have to be
like on the outskirts somewhere
yeah secondly which i have not done but
i need to
learn how to fly a helicopter or some
kind of
aerial device okay and make sure you're
fully stocked and whatever kind of fuel
it is
now uh you might go the route of
becoming some kind of
incredible scientist so inventing your
own stuff
to survive in solar panel
uh powered uh aerial device
okay you know or find a way to
bind a genius inventor person to you
you know by like hey so
i got blackmail or whatever it takes
i listen you just can't leave i mean
i also have survival skills so you know
i'm saying we should just group together
all these skills and that's that's a
third important one
put together a survival group
yes auditions will be held shortly
like what are you bringing to the table
um
i always say i'm like look i grew up in
nigeria i know how to
like you know i i know how to get my
food
and uh gather and also
um if need be i mean there's several
skills that come from
growing up in the motherland so
excellent so uh so i've already decided
to draft you for my zombie
um survival team this was an audition
thank you you passed that's really all i
was hoping for from all of this
totally to be a part of your team yes um
i have uh i have two alternate plans
um depending on what coast i happen to
be on the east coast
luckily is relatively lousy with
revolutionary
and civil war era forts um
and they're almost always in the water
because the whole idea was like this
defend against some dumbass ship from
england coming in so you're at the very
least only have
sort of three lanes that people can come
at you sometimes even only two
your back is to the water you have high
walls you can probably build some kind
of
gardening working farm inside there
um so yeah forts or houseboat
um i feel as if um people are sleeping
on houseboats when they start thinking
of their zombie preparedness
um there's a there you can absolutely
put solar power on that you don't have
to go that far into the water so you're
risking [ __ ] the perfect storm or
whatever um
you can grow on a houseboat you can have
enough soil you can do it you can filter
the water you can have your solar power
you can grow some food
you never need to go back on land if you
don't want to i like that
you know for a long time i was saying oh
catalina and then they had it
it doesn't but then it also makes me
think of world war
z you just keep going to any shallow
water because
apparently the zombies can just keep
walking through it until then yeah they
don't need the air so they can just
climb up the chains
and uh and make their way in so yeah you
want to be you don't want to be hitched
to a thing you don't want to be anchored
anywhere but if you just kind of went up
and down the coast
um in a houseboat the views are nice
you know you can fish okay you're
selling me on this houseboat
um you know it's it's you'd have to kind
of have it already in mind
before you need to prep you need to
become a zombie prepper
um but i'm just saying i'm just
saying i'm going to go on craigslist and
uh look up some of that
computer how much for houseboat
yeah siri um i want you to find me a
houseboat
um okay so i feel like we should get to
the news
news um
i didn't know that was the official uh
it isn't i just made it up
malcolm barrett at one point had written
um a news
theme song that he improved when he was
a guest host for a black man beyond
um i don't know how it goes because he's
[ __ ] malcolm and he's brilliant
but uh but we should we should find that
sound clip one more time
um all open i'm all ears for that yes
um today uh september 19th happens to be
batman day
um i would like i would encourage all of
you to go out and celebrate
by i don't know uh not wandering down
dark allies with your parents
maybe i don't know let's let's keep the
nuclear family intact as long as we can
um what is you know and there's no like
real batman
sort of media dropping i mean we'll get
to some harley quinn news later on
but sort of like batman day i was like
well okay you t
i don't know the answer to this question
so i'll ask you what is your favorite
moment
in a batman movie um i mean
you know there's so much joy to be had
in all of it but i was
what popped up was that first
introduction
of um of joker
um was played by the brilliant youth
ledger
oh okay and um
it just had me because it was also an
easter egg
back to the first um
see the first time joker came on the tv
series right
uh with that that mask was uh but it was
just
it was so beautifully done um i thought
it was i i went back and rewatched it um
that you know the great reveal you get a
sense of who this individual is as
they're all talking about him
he is the one navigating through that
space and
um basically puppeteering the whole uh
event is just it sticks with me
it was striking um
it was heath ledger indeed
it is uh it's a moment it's a moment how
about you
um mine is uh is is is
well okay it's the moment in batman
returns and it's
it's a ridiculous moment but i love it
to death where uh where bruce wayne
um you know commissioner gordon's like
oh [ __ ] some bad stuff has happened i'm
going to light the bat signal
and so it sends up the bat signal and it
like goes up into the sky
and then bounces from the sky down onto
a mirror
and then there's like nine other mirrors
that then bounce the light from the bat
signal into bruce wayne's
office and he just looks in the wall and
then there's a giant batting on the wall
he stands up and like his face rises in
the frame
it is so ridiculous that bruce wayne
had somebody clearly build a series of
mirrors to reflect a thing that's in the
sky
into his office but that also seems like
a total batman thing to do
you know it kind of defines him i know
you're like yeah obviously
obviously like he's prepared for
everything every contingency
you know probably drove around in the
batmobile and replaced those all
individually by himself
yeah also a thing he would have done
like like measures and surveying and
making sure
like the staff of raw the the light
would hit just at the right way and
angling the mirrors and it's uh it's
it's ridiculous
but but gloriously batman
i like it i like it a lot thank you yeah
i went on a limb there but
uh but [ __ ] it it's a it used to be a
batman podcast let's talk about batman a
little bit
um it also was the week that we got
the first trailer for the mandalorian
season two
were you were you a mandalorian fan well
you might know this
but um omid aptahi is
on the show who
yeah so here's the thing i'm actually
i'm waiting for
i want all the seasons as many seasons
as i can get
or a sit down and a binge because i know
it's one i'm just going to be upset
i'm going to be upset if i'm like i
watch one or two episodes
where's the where's the next thing what
am i what am i so i'm saving up
for a major binge on this one who made
major binge on this one
um i the the first season
um i at first was a little tepid on you
know i was like well
why is it because the episodes were like
38 minutes long and i'm like why is this
so
short and i don't understand what's
happening and
not enough happened and then i sort of
realized that uh
that every show teaches you how to watch
it and every show
at some point will uh will reveal what
it's going to be
and it just took me a couple of episodes
to realize that oh no all right i get it
i see the show they're trying to teach i
see what they're doing it's
and i i i never mean this as a
pejorative because some of my favorite
content is content for children
but it's a kids show like star wars has
always been a fable
you know it's always been a fable um
with like the cleanest morality in the
world
where the drama is super obvious where
it's also about this family
and it's like my dad's mean well my
sister's cool but i never met her
we got to go up against her dad but we
don't want to kill her dad somebody else
has got to kill her dad cause dad
he's good again like it's it's super
exactly how it's done too
that's exactly i'm pretty sure that was
the story break for the
star wars trilogy um but but yeah and so
realizing that
that my desire for star wars to grow up
with
me does not mean that star wars
is going to do that and so star wars
kind of has always been
on a level that kids can also understand
um
and and again that never means that it's
bad that never means that it's juvenile
i mean
the incredibles also exists on a level
that is built
for children to understand but has a
[ __ ] ton of stuff for adults
like everything pixar is working on
these two levels i mean the warner
brothers cartoons that i grew up loving
are also working on two levels the
simpsons is working on two levels all
this stuff
is is is is making it accessible
to everybody and and you know when you
got into stuff like
all right well it's it's trade
negotiations and uh
and and embargoes for taxation purposes
and
senate procedurals it's like i feel like
we've forgotten that star wars is for
kids
um and so the mandalorian actually kind
of cycles it back to being like oh
all right it's kind of for children
children's attention spans or about 35
to 40 minutes
kids really love puppets what if we have
the cutest puppet in the world
everybody loves that puppet and by the
time you get to the end of the season i
was fully under its spell i was fully
just like oh no yeah i see what they're
doing i love what they're doing
and and that was even above and beyond
the technical achievement of the show
which is oh no yeah we shot this all in
the sound stage there were no locations
we're just literally indoors for you
know 40 weeks of production
and so when i saw the the season 2
trailer i was like oh
yeah bring me more of this because this
is exactly what i want
make it happen please um i think we have
it are we gonna roll it have we started
rolling it i think it's rolling
is it rolling is it doing things it is
oh yeah there's a ship
um so if you've never seen any of the
mandalorian you're like this doesn't
mean anything to me
no but here's the thing it does because
i saw this trailer and
i you know it had me hooked and i'm like
do i start earlier than i meant to
you know i mean it's it's doing the
thing that a good trailer does which is
making it irresistible
yeah and uh the greatest puppet in the
world
the cutest like the first the first
season they were super
like you know tight about baby yoda or
the child or whatever his actual name is
um
but uh but here in the trailer like look
at all these baby yoda's we're lousy
with it you get a yoda you get a yogurt
come to your chair i bet you there's a
yoder um
and uh i'm i'm glad to see that carl
weathers is back because carl weathers
was a was a pleasant surprise
again you didn't see the first season
but anytime i get carl weathers
i'm super happy yeah um because i grew
up
what your face was like well no because
i'm seeing moments that just have me
wait what what's happening
but sorry you were saying no no carl
weathers i grew up a huge rocky fan
and so anytime i get to see apollo
create anywhere i'm just super happy and
like
he's you know easy in his late 60s early
70s and still a [ __ ] badass
wow this moment
yeah you don't see that that often where
it's just we're gonna go to black
yep we are two minutes we're giving you
four seconds of black
yeah you gotta have you know absolute
faith in what you know what you're
selling what you're sharing there or
else uh
right and so happy to see what i thought
um
i'm pretty sure was a glimpse of rosario
dawson as ahsoka tano
in there and so excited i'm so excited
you got me all excited for it but i
don't know i'm gonna start this early
and i
probably won't sleep for the next two
days and then what will end up happening
is that i'm all done and which is why
i'm not starting it yet
it's because i need enough to last like
you know at least a month
i know i mean we have no idea how long
we're going to be quarantined for and so
we have to begin to sort of ration out
our goodness isn't it possibly until
2021
[Laughter]
pretty much pretty much um
so yes excited for that to drop um in
october um
october 30th i think is when season two
on spools and i can't wait
can't wait can't wait um
we talked a bit about lovecraft country
um
and uh the sort of the the surprising
news of this week
was that uh jonathan majors who stars in
lovecraft's country as
as atticus is heading to the mcu
in of all things ant-man 3
as of all characters kang the conqueror
what what
i'm just so happy for him oh hell yeah
and i cannot get enough of him it's you
know
hey now that moment where he uh you know
he put on the glasses and then he kind
of hooked it behind his ear i mean not
just
yeah and like he's always running around
those tank tops like yeah i get it's the
gun show every time
tick shows up for me though
it's the glasses for me so you know if
we can
have those moments as many times more as
possible
yeah but i think that you know what
what's what seems to be unfair
is that he can also do the glasses while
wearing a tank top
with those arms it's like dude come on
come on listen i am not mad at that
i mean it's just not fair to everybody
else
it's like come on [ __ ] just pick
one it's like hemsworth like why are you
all so funny
like you don't have to be funny looking
like that yeah funny
and uh just gorgeous yeah you could be
dumb as a stump
and get along just fine no
but it was weird there was one episode i
don't know what it was he did something
or there's something in the way he moved
that reminded me
of um patrick swayze in ghost
that had me thinking oh what if he did
ghost
i want more ghosts oh ghost but with him
yeah um just i'm so excited for this
news i'm so excited for him
yeah i mean and i would not have i would
not have pegged ant-man 3
as this sort of deployment zone for king
and the conqueror
but also totally down for it i'm here
for it i'm here for it all day
yes all day every day um i uh
and for those at home you know carrying
the conquerors or this time
traveling you know would be despot
who uh who i mean and we've had our fair
share of time travel in the marvel
universe
um you know maybe a little too much i
don't know
but you have too much time travel can
you have to we can always just go back
and fix it if we
have too much time travel i like it i
like it a lot
like it um so yeah i think that
uh there's no release date for it yet
because who the hell knows when anybody
is getting back to production for
anything but i'm super excited to see
now way more excited for ant-man 3 than
i was before
they did their job there because i mean
i mean paul rudd is pretty amazing
though he is that like non-problematic
um like ageless probably a vampire
yeah clearly yeah he's definitely a
vampire right like we know this for a
fact
it must be must i mean like
there's a bathtub full of blood
somewhere in his property that he just
bathes in
after that or some kind of painting you
know yeah
um
listen there's a painting of paul
giamatti just
like i'm sorry paul i gotta take a few
more years
i you know i look i don't want to be
responsible for spreading
uh fake news but i don't know i've got
an eye on you paul
could be could be um elsewhere in the
marvel universe
um we got a she-hulk who the hell knew
we were going to get a she-hulk
um i appreciate marvel giving us good
news during a time when we could all use
some good news
so excited for tatiana masani yes
cha-cha i mean i
i remember watching orphan black and
just saying
who is this person doing all of this
work
and and i just not not since
and and i'll blow her up only because
she's a friend but
and i'll always say that trisha helfer's
work on battle star
playing what was ultimately like seven
or eight different versions of the same
basic character and keeping them all
straight
um and that was like basically her first
job
you know and and it's it's a it's a it's
an immense
task to ask an actor to do and a joy to
ask an actor to do but it's a lot
and so tatiana felt like it was the the
evolutionary leap of
not only i'm gonna play five characters
that are different but totally alike
i'm gonna do the same time they're gonna
be in the same scenes
and i'm gonna have dance parties with me
and my clones and it's gonna be amazing
i mean for one thing i didn't feel yes
she got some critical acclaim but i
still didn't feel that she got
um we we didn't give her enough of her
flowers
because what she did i'm looking at it
as a fellow actor
is just mind-blowing um
by going back to battlestar that's
another one that if it was around now
would be getting all the awards i think
yeah you know like it's so hard to
believe that a show
that was written as well as it was
written starring
[ __ ] edward james almost you know and
and you know laura mc it's it's i think
mayor mcdonnell is the best and i just
can't imagine that
neither of those actors would actually
get the shine that they would have
gotten today
um and it seems that slowly we're we're
beginning to
reward our genre performers for the
excellence and the quality that they do
but there are so many that never got as
you say they're flowers that they should
have
you never got their flowers and i always
think of battlestar as kind of the
precursor to
genre tv that we have right now right if
it wasn't for them we wouldn't be seeing
um all of these shows start to get the
recognition i feel like that's what made
a lot of people wake up to the fact that
you can have
genre uh tv
stories and that they can be critically
acclaimed they can be really well pieced
together
um and taken um i don't like to use the
term taken seriously
it's that you know that they do hold
weight um so i'm hoping that we give
tatiana all the
all the credit that she deserves with
this one i'm so happy for her
indeed you know we're we are the night
before the emmys um
during which um fingers crossed watchmen
continues to perform incredibly well
and i think there is a direct line that
you can draw from
you know the the the way we are
recognizing the awesomeness that is
watchmen
to the kind of content that was being
produced in the sort of
mid to late arts lately stuff like
battlestar
you know which is like oh no we're going
to use this
framework of genre and within it also
tell
these thematically trenching stories
about war
and terrorism and abortion and
pandemics and so forth and so on and
and and still have it be i know it's
about robots who are trying to kill us
but also be about fundamentally the
human experience and what that is
and watchmen just took it to the
again an evolutionary leap to oh yeah no
it's going to be about race but also
about dudes and costumes punching each
other in the face
a lot like oh sweet and regina king just
killing it
and regina king just killing it so yeah
and [ __ ] lou gossett jr
like yeah
it was i feel like we need a moment of
silence for just that i know just for
the fact that like
is that louis gossett jr holy [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] loose
and he's he's killing it like why
haven't we been killing it with him for
like 20 years now
right you know why why didn't he get the
[ __ ] like
martin sheen career of just i'm just
gonna keep doing these roles into my 50s
60s and 70s why isn't he michael douglas
i mean you laugh but i asked those
questions daily
those are fair questions to ask um yeah
so i'm very excited
for she-hulk um jessica gal is the head
writer who's leading the writer's room
she comes from the rick and morty camp
um and uh and yeah i think that that
tatiana as the last major character to
be created by stan lee
jessica walters aka um she-hulk
should be and i and i wonder if i have
to think there's gonna be some cg
involved
in her um hulking out because
i'm thinking that's going to be the case
unless you go the route
of like the old school tv show i would
love it if they did that
one would that be if like you know gina
carrano shows up just painted green
like in oh did she hulk
i uh i i second your your notion i feel
like that's the way to go
that is totally awake you know marvel
you can send the checks to me
when yes and all the money you would
save on cgi
totally look at that you can go so much
faster you know
just like all right uh she hooks in and
then in comes your she-hulk actress and
all right jessica walters out
there's no rendering time you just gotta
spray paint somebody green
that's it simple enough um i feel like
we should uh
they should take that idea and in
exchange they should cast you a storm
uh i wouldn't be
you know too upset with that i mean what
me play storm
i said before uh no couldn't be i do
declare
mr mr disney that would be an excellent
idea i don't know city slick a lawyer
i feel like we can come to some
arrangement on my behalf
and play in your weather characters
with the characters i love that i'm
going to steal that
i'm using that from now on yes ix and my
expertise is in weather characters
and weather characters but only if you
get to write it
done deal deal so uh we will give all of
your ideas to marvel in exchange
for a one picture deal uh one picture
deal
it's three pictures yeah pretty pictures
don't think so small son
well rotten this to the bank i do
declare somehow i turned into foghorn
leghorn in the middle of that and i'm
not sure when
they up and i'm loving every single
second of it but yeah
i mean if you you know that's something
that people wanted to just throw out
there yes
yeah yeah i mean i feel like the
campaign um is is small but passionate
and i feel like we can grow it i feel
like it's a platform that we can all
agree on
oh man especially after that pitch i
mean it's done
duh weather captain in the mail
oh hello like eight o'clock at night no
but hello there's a delivery for you
from mr marvel
oh it's mr marble the marvelous mr
marvel
is here to present me with a contract a
standard rich and famous contract
to star as their premier weather
character
a standard rich and famous contract i
oh my goodness i just had that because
that's just pure gold
uh well i will i will happily take
credit for a thing i just stole
but uh that was uh in the muppet show
when kermit wants to go to hollywood and
he finally gets
he sings the rainbow connection and then
orson welles was like bring me a
standard rich and famous contract and
then kermit happily signs it and it's
like yeah
and then they go kermit nuts and does
the arms like that for sure arms like
that
um so yeah i i only steal from the best
um i think we have one more one more hit
in our marvel news um which is
that um ms marvel disney pluses ms
marvel show
um disney plus yeah
i i i feel like it's like the canal plus
but of streaming services
so disney plus make it sound fancy
um you know and they're making this
marvelous show which i'm super excited
about
um especially after having played the
character a little bit in marvel
avengers video game
and uh and and the fact that they're
just swinging into like yeah we're gonna
tell this story about this pakistani
american muslim teenager who also
happens to be
a kick-ass [ __ ] superhero um without
sacrificing either
of those parts of her personality and
parts of her identity
in order to tell the story um is
is a is a leap forward to say the least
because there are not a ton of shows
that are based around pakistani american
muslim teenagers
um and the fact that they are embracing
all of the things that make that
character special and both in front of
and behind the camera
and so marvel has hired a bunch of
directors to sort of form the sort of
core
of their directorial um unit um
and it's like a bunch of you know
there's a there's a pakistani
director in there there's a couple of of
what what seem to be at least middle
eastern north american
or north african um filmmakers adil
arby and the lyle fala who made uh bad
boys for life
who've been tapped to work on episodes
charming obeyed chinoy who
won an oscar two-time oscar winner in
the documentary short category
um and uh and mira menon who's been
working on stuff like wong dead punisher
titans dirty john and outlander
are all coming to work to make uh to
make kamala khan
um which it's also weird because i've
been told how to pronounce kamala
two different ways very recently like
kamala harris right kamala khan
like okay could we get on the same page
just but i i gotta say it is it is a
pretty
amazing um show of you know
actually uh looking
to do the diverse story correctly
and actually actually caring about
representation on
all sides uh in front of the camera and
behind the camera like you mentioned
and i mean i'm it makes me very hopeful
or that this is the kind of thing we're
going we're going to see
where we want truthful representations
of
of historically oppressed individuals or
historically underrepresented
individuals being handled with such care
yeah you know and it's and it's great
that it's
marvel doing it because certainly marvel
doesn't have to do it
you know they can you know it's marvel
they're too certain to be bulletproof
um but they they understand that
they can also be an example they can
also be like hey guys
we're we don't have to do it we're doing
it you know it because we feel like it's
going to be better for it
you know and and we could spend the
money on
the you know the the dozens and dozens
of of caucasian filmmakers who are crazy
expensive
but we can absolutely get them to do
this but what's better for us
here is to give that same number of
monies to people who are
underrepresented
who can can can make this as authentic
as possible
yeah and yeah it's it only takes one
person to start to kind of like lead the
way
and it's it's reassuring to me
that it comes from a a geek house like
yeah you know what
let's do this the right way i appreciate
it but i also think it's because there's
representation
within the you know the executive sides
as well and i think that's part of the
reason that we're seeing
such um well thought out uh
examples um and that to me is
the main reason we continually need to
push
for representation i'm going to get off
my soap box in a second
stay out there as long as you want you
got the hat the hat the hat plays
okay but it's just um
yeah when you have people in in
positions of
for lack of a better word power who are
also representative
it's i think it then starts to reflect
um
um on the talent level as well and uh
behind the camera it all you know it all
feeds into each other
yeah you know and it and it i think the
work is
better for it you know it's it's one of
those like
if you if you cook according to the
recipe but if you also have a little bit
of the understanding
of the reason why we're using these
ingredients and the reasons why they're
incorporated in such a way
that it's going to taste better you know
and so just
like understanding
your own ignorance and i have it as well
as i think we all have some blind spots
um but as long as we can acknowledge
them and understand them and attempt to
dismantle them and
replace them with actual content that
that seems
relevant and and authentic everything
gets better
great so we've solved hollywood so done
we're out we've got some questions what
else can we solve
um to to pivot away from the marvel
universe for a bit
uh it came down the pike that harley
quinn is getting a third season on hbm
have you seen any of the harley quinn
i've only seen them as much as you all
shared with me so i appreciate that
yes um it's fantastic it's profane
it's uh it's glorious um
uh i i think you'll dig it the most but
um
it uh it's second season showing hbo max
they got a third season now and with
that news of a third season for
harley quinn comes the news of the
demise of the dc
universe as a scripted uh production
entity
um and they had they've been behind doom
patrol and swamp thing
and titans and and harley quinn
much of which much of that content has
been ported over at this point to hbo
max
if not cancel that right which is what
happened to poor swamp thing
um star girl was supposed to premiere as
an hb as a as a
dc universe shiny thing and that went
over to the cw
um because for some reason
and i can't explain why warner media
doesn't quite
have uh didn't have their ducks in a row
when they were launching both hbo max
you know a year after launching dc
universe because they didn't have a
conversation with us
because we had apparently all the
answers we do like guys you only need
one of these apps
you kind of don't need both and maybe a
dc specific app isn't the way to go
because
yeah but they seem to be finally
correcting course and you can't ever you
can't ever hold a person
liable for realizing they made a mistake
and pivoting accordingly
so good for you warner media for
realizing that maybe we didn't need both
of these things and we're going to take
the stuff that worked on one
move it over to the other and now dc
universe will be renamed dc universe
infinite
as their own um sort of comics reader
app
where they're going to have some ungodly
amount of comic books available it's
like 24
000 titles spanning eight decades
um that you can for a subscription which
i'm assuming will be less than you're
paying for
scripted content um have access to all
this stuff it's like comixology or
marvel unlimited um but now it's for dc
and so you know good for them for not
letting a thing go
thoroughly to waste but uh instead of
just the false start that was
dc streaming stuff i mean
i guess i will have to get that
subscription as well too but i always
feel kind of weird
doing all that like you know i feel like
i'm like cheating on somebody
you know i have my marvel unlimited and
i'm like okay i'm going through and i'm
you know reading all my storm stuff and
then i'm like
but you know i still love you while i
you know
i'm subscribing to this service as well
it's just
you're very different it's like apples
and oranges i'm going to be glamorous
about my comics
i feel like you know in some cases you
know
you should be allowed to love more than
one thing
this is what i'm saying so i'm just
going to tell everyone mark told me to
mark said be willy-nilly
with your your amorousness and just love
all things
which is pretty much me anyway so willy
nilly
[Laughter]
um okay here's
two little quick hits um mulan
which which dropped on the disney plus
premier access a couple of weeks ago
according to yahoo finance it uh the
disney mulan's purchase rate hit
29 for u.s subscriber households
which you know sort of translates to if
they have about 30 million subscribers
um and 29 of them paid 30 to watch it
they made 260 million dollars in revenue
in less than two weeks in just the us
which if that's a theatrical release
pretty strong you know like that's
probably a
you know 180 million opening weekend
with a
sort of 80 million dollar second weekend
which is pretty strong for a movie like
that and just in the u.s
and you didn't have to pay a dime in
distribution and you didn't have to
share anything with exhibitors
like not bad not you know like i i know
that that
amc and carmike and all of these these
theater chains
don't really want to hear it but it
seems that there's an audience for this
kind of release pattern
and they will pay their money if it's
the right
piece of content and the money they pay
will
be kind of exactly the money you want if
you're a studio
you know like i think disney's all in
was about 200 million dollars to produce
it and they made that money back in two
weeks
um yeah i i remember getting oddly
i did not expect to get so emotional
over it
[Laughter]
sobbing and i'm like
and it's also like i'm crying and i also
share that emotion
for a story that i absolutely know what
happens in
yeah i know what's next there were some
fun
you know additions totally you know
there was some little tweaks to the
formula and
which all of which made sense there was
also some like very convenient character
turns
where it's just like here's where her
commanding officer needs to suddenly
believe her
and so he does for no reason i still
cried through it
even though not believable yeah totally
it's like and why does she take her
armor off and let her hair down like how
is that a good thing
going into battle so that wasn't just me
because i'm like
going into battle i know they need to
know that you're a lady but
usually you know you just do the hair
flip thing you know like pull out the
hair band
and uh everyone will be like oh yeah and
it's also
not like when she took off her armor
suddenly she's jessica rabbit
underneath it it's like she's still
wearing like relatively billowy clothing
and she still kind of looks like a dude
who suddenly has lipstick and long hair
yeah it was kind of random but i say all
that and like to sound all cool but i
was
i was i was sobbing yeah no it's it's
it's a relatively bulletproof story
that uh that delivers emotional content
uh directly to your face and tear ducts
so so yeah there there is now a an
example
for studios to to operate off of
um which is with the right piece of
material
targeted the right audience they will
absolutely pay
um 30 to watch it um over and over and
over again it helps that it's a kid's
movie
you know it helps that it's disney it
helps that it's got the pre-awareness
and the branding
i'm not sure if you know tenant would
have worked the same way
um because there are people who'll just
wait like you know
parents with children in a pandemic will
happily spend
whatever to get them to stop they just
throw it at you
watch a thing just give me two hours can
you give me
30 for two hours of my time back done
but this has actually been something
i've been thinking about for quite a
while even before the pandemic happened
because i was looking at you know the
the numbers of uh
for theater goers and that's really
shifting
even before we were um we were
forced to be at home and
in in my mind it had always made sense
to start
a model and i'm curious who would look
to that
of you know this kind of release in
the states but in places like i keep
saying africa is so
untapped and africa i mean africa
the continent all the countries within
them because
you know there there was for quite a
while
um uh this growth happening for theaters
and came like a bit of a status thing to
then
go to the theater in the way that
uh we used to have it i think in the
states
a bit more and that it was an event
right that you went out for and so i
felt like as
those numbers are dropping for that here
and new theaters are being built
in you know all across africa by uh
silver bird
that it for me our release model that
made sense was
to have it available to stream out here
and then in places where people
were going to um be willing to spend a
whole lot more
just to have the event
have it there it's you know but again
there's me trying to close
know again not a bad idea
solve it we're fixing [ __ ] y'all can pay
me later
yes in weather characters
um i would like four weather characters
please
um our last story for the evening um
is you know i don't know if this is a
good idea or a bad idea or just a thing
we'll all watch
to see if horrible things happen but
there's a reality tv show that's going
to be called space hero
which will send the winning contestant
to outer space
um it's a production company founded by
uh
thomas riemer and deborah sass and led
by some people from news corp
um and like ben silverman um who ran
nbc for a while but like a selected
group of contestants will undergo
extensive training and face challenges
testing their physical mental and
emotional strength
qualities that are essential for an
astronaut in space and the culmination
the competition
where they will broadcast live this
person launching into
um the iss i believe it is um
space here is currently in negotiations
with nasa to make it happen
would you do this would you be a
contestant on space hero
okay so here's the thing i'm not usually
i'm not usually the person for reality
shows
to say um but i love space
i got a little puppet a lot to the point
you don't understand even up to last
year i was still applying to jpl i'm
like please hire me for some kind of
position
and they're like there's this person
pretending to be a teenager jackie that
keeps playing i'm like no
i swear it's me i swear it's me hi
i want space i want space give me face
i mean you know on my twitter where i
say you know trying to get to mars
i'm not joking i would be there
yesterday
i mean i feel like mars is probably
nicer than it is here
probably i mean the weather's better i
don't know yeah i mean you can stay
inside you have to stay inside but like
it's way less crowded
less fires for sure earthquakes not so
many times
no viruses there at all no murder
hornets
no murder horde as far as we know yeah i
mean
and it might be a place to escape a
zombie thing unless you happen to take
an infected person with you and then
everybody's just you know
there's gonna be that one guy who like
doesn't declare it at the airport it's
like do you have any livestock or uh
living matter
or zombie bites yeah no
yeah anybody sick anybody come in
contact with the pathogens
no damn it milt you were bitten by a
zombie
and you brought it to mars zombies you
[ __ ] up another planet
why you [ __ ] up the last one now we're
going to a noon you [ __ ] this one up too
yeah but it's um so you know
when i found out about this i was like
do i want to
apply
could i like please go
um because yeah i love space and uh
you know this may be one that i would
end up watching them surprised
they got me yeah i i would probably
watch
i would hope that they would treat it
with some level of reverence
yeah you know and not like here's the
daffy puzzle challenge to figure out who
gets a helmet this week
bad there's that version of it there's
totally the the like crappy
survival challenge version of it i would
assume they wouldn't go that route
because you know you're going up to the
international space station and there
are a lot of people that you could
endanger if you're not you know if you
don't have it together
yes my viewpoint on it yeah we
like play it fair play it for real it
should be like the right stuff but sure
there's also going to be the hi my name
is phil
i run a bail shop in philadelphia and i
want to go to space
hey i'm phil and phil's a great guy i
don't know what you have against bill
i have nothing against phil or
philadelphia bagels but i'm saying
that i would i would hope that it's the
best of the best
and not like randos
i agree and part of it though uh too is
because
there was a while i was doing research
for film i was going to do
um that kind of disappeared but
um but to see how much people
put in to try and get up and people
trying for years and have been trying
their whole
pretty much their whole lives and have
serious degrees
and serious um uh like know-how about
all of uh the goings on there it
it would be an absolute shame if they
did
not treat it with the reverence that is
due yeah
that that is all i would ask uh people
behind space hero
um i i don't need it to be a bunch of
like
we're forming an alliance and uh we just
don't like that dude because he's a nerd
and you know like the way most american
reality tv is
hopeful fingers crossed um so yeah that
i think
is uh is the end of the news bag um
thank you today for
for rolling the news with me um thank
you
i can't believe i got to do that with
with mark
you were the best and you knew more
about it than kev ever knows about
anything so you
win i'm pretty sure kevin wins
everything
[Laughter]
uh jc uh i i know that you're on there
you've been monitoring the chat um do we
have any questions from our um
viewers that are hanging around i i do
have some questions
uh the first one is from renee descartes
um and they would like to know
uh if you were to write and direct a
movie that is currently confirmed for
release which movie and whom
does yatida play oh
a movie that is currently scheduled for
release
um and who does yati play
weather characters all the weather
characters um
uh okay if i was gonna write and direct
a movie that's currently slated for
release i would write and direct
dune hmm um and i think
i would cast yatide
as um
see i mean it's easy to cast you as
chani like that's that's the easy way to
go but i feel like
i feel like lady jessica has more in
it i feel like there's there's an
imperiousness there to play
there's a there's some there's some real
strength and grit and there's a
transformation of character
in that and you're also like you know
member of the benny jesuit faith and so
you get to do awesome cool [ __ ] like
i feel like that's that's that's the way
i'd go i'm on board for that and
also i would just want a whole bunch of
scenes where it's me like staring at
you know the camera like this and then
my thoughts
are being the beginning is a very
delicate time
that is my favorite part of watching
like old school
dune is just what they spent like it
feels like hours of the movie or them
just inking
stuff oh yeah my name is a killing word
[Laughter]
should i have another person i can say
this to no no you're fine you're fine
you're fine
um yeah and then go into whole you know
here's the mind killer yeah i love it i
see we did it i i like to imagine the
production of dune
being a bunch of people just standing on
set
while the camera's rolling and people
shouting off screen
the narration that they've already
spoken before so
there's just dudes standing there like
looking at each other meanwhile
like this yes not yet i will not kill
the baron yet
i must wait for my time
my name is a killing word it is the
prophecy
where do i sign for the rich and famous
entrepreneur
i'm told yes dune to electric boogaloo
we will totally get you
but i mean on a serious note too i would
love to like to play jessica
like to see a black woman in that role
i'm i'm into it yes faux show
for sure i mean i'm glad zendaya
but she's doing a lot of work
[Laughter]
no i once worked with her back in the
day she probably doesn't remember
because i was like
well did i technically work with her it
was on her disney show
i was this evil british lady
you know as you do as you do my name is
madame
blimber schmidt remember what her name
and then i got flipped over by by the
you know there was the the young child
that was a robot
oh my i missed her show on disney
channel
back in the day you know before uh
so it's amazing to see everything that
she's she's doing she's killing it
everybody's gotta start somewhere um
okay so yeah that's that's the answer
dune
and your today's lady jessica tradies
all right next question is from doc
nguyen
they are interested in knowing what
remakes you want to start today
knowing full well it may take years to
actually make
so that it would be relevant to the
world when it comes out
that's a good question that's a good
question i mean it's a hard question to
answer because
um there's no way to reliably predict
what the world is going to be in let's
say five years
um there are some things that you could
you know at the very least say
won't change that much um sadly
there's some there's some elements to
you know both american life and global
life that seem to uh
to persist despite
um best efforts um i.e
racism sexism misogyny all of those
things
um yeah lots of isms that we can't seem
to
to squeeze out of the formula um
but i think a remake that would speak to
where the world is um
i don't know why my head is going to
smoky in the bandit
but uh but i kind of would like to see
a smoky in the bandit that is like
jonathan majors is the bandit
and uh and and and like john amos
as smokey and like because there's
something about that story that's very
like southern and very sort of rebel
yell
and you know confederate flag on the
license plate and all that stuff and to
find a way to subvert that
while still also being about you know a
rebel streak
and you know american rebellion and all
that
but having the rebels be somebody that
you wouldn't imagine
as the rebels and and have it also be a
little bit about
you know the the the road experience of
your average black person
in america um and and what actually you
are taking
your life in your hands when you choose
to speed when you when you're actually
staring down the barrel of the police
officers
again i'm 100 miles an hour i dare you
to stop me knowing that that i won't get
a ticket on the other
end of that um i don't know i have no
idea what the story is beyond
i gotta get x across the border in such
and such a time
and i'm putting black people where they
used to be white people um but
uh but yeah i think we will keep having
conversations about race and policing
going forward and if there's a way to to
subvert that and also still have it be
charming and so have it be a little
light on its feet and still have it be
kind of thrilling and actiony while also
being about something else
um i would like my standard rich and
famous contract now please
wait there's someone at the door hello
it's me uh papa mgm i've got your rich
and famous contract right here
oh see i think there's one i'd love to
see you right and i think i've mentioned
this one before
more on a hopeful note um is we
we know how in like all the in star trek
and all that mythology
there's the idea that we passed we grew
up through
a certain period and i would like to see
that
incorporated into a film of like
yeah this was the inciting incident like
this was the period that made us go you
know what we need to get our stuff
together
you know create a united front and also
let's say hello to the aliens and maybe
that's coming
[Laughter]
maybe what makes the aliens say you know
what those earth people not so bad
we're not going to lock the door when we
drive by anymore i know
i know i i do find it amazing um
all the time that this is also the year
that the government was like oh yeah
ufos totally exist
like yeah no hear the pictures hear the
files like [ __ ] yeah
there they go and everyone's like yeah
yeah that's cool but um
but murder hornets and and and just
regular murder like have you met those
things
um but the the idea that aliens have
been coming by
relatively frequently and have not
chosen to stop because we are
still a garbage fire yeah i think that's
actually how they described us when you
know they did the debriefings they were
like earth
is a literal garbage fire you know yeah
it's it's like own risk when we decode
the music they play to try to
communicate it just says garbage fire
over and
i feel over that's that is what that's
already the name of the band right
uh i don't know it should be there's
garbage terrestrial garbage fire
terrestrial garbage or extraterrestrial
either one works
nice i feel like we uh we're gonna form
a a
a punk band like uh again just very
angry
about the fact that we're a garbage fire
nice to meet you tonight we are the band
terrestrial garbage fire
we're gonna melt your face and talk
about sex and stuff terrestrial garbage
fire
wow all the best ideas these are gold
these are gold these
we should give these away like sorry
we're cutting the stream we're just
going to keep these ideas
for ourselves um all right jc
um what else we got all right rose twins
2x2
is interested in knowing if you could
own any car from a predominantly black
or a person of color
movie or genre property what would it be
uh they like blades impala
okay that's uh that's pretty good i'm
trying to think
what can beat that a predominantly
black movie that had a badass
car and genre um
i mean they're they're really [ __ ]
narrowing the the pipe here
like where am i added on the genre maybe
yeah was there was genre in there jc or
is is your teenager
or genre person of color black or genre
property
i go i'll throw out uh uh
adonis creed's mustang in creed that he
loses was fantastic
nice okay all right excellent no no i
feel like we got the parameters right
okay um
see here's the thing like i i'm going to
modify the question
to say it was also driven by a black
person not necessarily predominantly
black movie
because i want to choose isaac hayes
car as the duke of new york and escape
from new york
um which had the chandeliers on the
front instead of headlights
um it was the coolest thing i had seen
that wasn't like you know because i was
a big fan of night riders a big fan of
the generally
problematic fave to say the least um but
but
that car just spoke of opulence and
power and ridiculousness
like it's it's like the batmobile it's
the black mobile it's the batmobile for
like
black people because what is it it's a
giant freaking caddy
it's a land yacht with with chandeliers
on the front
do we not have the black mobile yet
because that sounds like something
that's
happening if you know again
good idea that we're just not we're
getting into the world
yeah it's just for free yeah it's all
yours
go be free i would choose the
blackmobile i mean it doesn't exist yet
apparently but
we're making again we're making it right
now
done um all right i feel like blades
impala is a good pick i feel like uh
creed's mustang is a good pick and and
i'm going to stand
by the duke of new york a number one's
um chandelier encrusted land yacht
um all right let's do let's do two more
jc alrighty uh darius taylor
has thrown out for many weeks in a row
uh and is super interested
in knowing who you guys think should
play static shock
who should play young virgil hawkins
uh you know
i'm i'm of two minds um i'm of the mind
of like
find somebody new and make a star
you know the thing that hollywood used
to do all the time which is like
hey would you like to meet natalie wood
she's great
hey this is you know michael caine's
first movie
lawrence of arabia introducing peter
o'toole like
i feel like we we for ip like this we
try a little too hard
to find you know somebody who's already
acting and already in the world
where you could just open casting call
find me the best person find me
find me stormread i can tell you a name
that i don't think
many people know yet and he would be
phenomenal jordan hall
look him up if you haven't got to do a
film with him
about gosh how many years ago it was
called what we found
and he got to you know he was a lead and
this was his first time
um before that he had done um he
he has an incredible voice so he had
done disney um
boring uh disney musicals i think it was
like lion king and stuff uh playing a
simba
but he's so talented he's so dedicated
and speaking to what you're saying about
how there are these incredible people
out there
not necessarily getting all these
opportunities
i i mean i could see him already just
kill it um i just
wish more people were you know giving
him the opportunities that he i think he
so rightfully deserves so jordan paul
look up that name because
he's brilliant jordan hall um i
will secondly today's pick even though i
i cannot bring him to mind but you got
taste so we'll roll that way
um i'd also add um jarel jerome who was
in
um um ava duvernay's amazing
um netflix sort of
the central park five mini series she
made
um and i'm pretty sure that he won
either an emmy or golden globe
for that um but yeah he's he's fantastic
um but yeah i i like that idea of like
bring me a fresh face bring me somebody
you know who who i haven't seen before
who could absolutely kill this
and and just engage with it in a way
that
you know there's something really lovely
energy wise
about somebody who realizes that this is
their thing
you know and that that level of just
investment
and like this is my shot and i'm gonna
give it everything
um and who knows i'm gonna get another
shot so i'm gonna leave it all in the
field i'm gonna leave everything on the
stage i'm just i'm
there's no holding back this is this is
everything for me and and
if if i ever get the opportunity to
start casting people and stuff that
that i get to write it's find me that
person who is invested in it being a
success as much as you are
for whom it is not just another role for
whom it is it is some kind of dream come
true and
if art yeah i mean it
it it helps you all row in the same
direction
right where you're all trying to make a
thing good
and you're all as invested in its
success as
as as each other and yeah it helps you
hopefully build a team it helps you
build a unit that all wants to succeed
and uh and so yeah find a new person
find it you know
make somebody's life it's somebody's
life i want that on a t-shirt
make somebody's life um
all right i think we got one more
question jc yeah all right last one is
from braden
gossey what do you think deserves a
biopic
if it hasn't if they haven't gotten one
yet
or who deserves a better biopic than
they got
what you got by now you've heard me talk
about zynga right uh i i the name is
familiar but tell the people
okay she's a 17th century congolese
queen
um she was brilliant she managed to
in her lifetime drive out
the slavers um they did come back after
she
after she passed because people were not
able to hold up
but she's literally a warrior queen
with this incredible mind she is
braveheart meets elizabeth meets
cleopatra and this is a woman that
lived through history that we don't tend
to hear about and it's just
you see this epic picture and the way i
came across her
was actually i saw a picture that was uh
recreated by a portuguese capuchin
of the meeting that she had with the
portuguese
to negotiate with them which she totally
she pulled the rug out from underneath
them but they had removed all the
furniture
around her so that when she arrived
she would have to stand before them as a
supplicant
they removed that so that she would know
her place
he walks in with a retinue of warriors
they see the situation without breaking
stride one of the warriors gets down on
his hands and knees
she sits on her back does on his back
does the whole meeting
from there and that already had
themselves like what just
happened uh so much so that they had to
record it in history and there's a kind
of
begrudging respect of her um
because this woman was incredible
and i just want to see that film now i
want to see that film
yeah why don't we have that film why
don't we have that build
i'm trying to come on hollywood
another one we have to talk about so yes
no that's
holy [ __ ] that sounds amazing um
that's yours and yours is so much better
than mine
um because yeah as with all things
um but i'm i'm gonna go with
uh hannibal hannibal of barca the great
general
who uh who sort of brought rome to its
feet um
who was from africa and who marched
elephants across the alps and who
you know just he he he is for
that's the reason why we know that we
have the name hannibal like it's not
it's not like he was in a baby book and
people are choosing hannibal as a name
for people
um it's because he was a titanic figure
of of
history and especially military history
and that story
um has never adequately been told on the
screen
um and i would also advocate for when
i've done it before in the podcast and
i'll do it again until it happens um
alexandra dumas who wrote the three
musketeers and the counter money christo
um had a father who was
the only black general in napoleon's
army
who was born in haiti um
uh and and like transcended and like he
was born free in haiti
um came from money came back to france
where everybody is free in france like
apparently that was part of the code
um once you set foot on french land
you're free um enlisted in the army and
became
like ultimately is the model for the
count of monte cristo he was the
the good man who was betrayed by the
people that he loved and sentenced
to prison um who then would escape
um but instead of executing his revenge
he just went and had like a quiet small
life
on the other end of it but um
but it's a it's an insane romantic
daring do adventure filled um
story that uh that at one point
idris elba was going to star in like a
an fx miniseries that never happened
um but yeah there's a book called the
black count which is phenomenal and
tells that story
but i mean it's it's it is one of those
here's the man who inspired the greatest
adventure stories ever told
um and he was real and he existed and
his son
would document these stories and invent
um
and embroider them with flair and and
daring do
um merely to help turn his father who he
didn't know very much into the hero that
the world never saw him as
um so yeah i would do either of those
after we did zynga because holy crap
that's well i want to see both of those
now too we should just make all of them
we should make all those again hollywood
we're just we're here
just spinning gold for you i don't know
what else you want
[Laughter]
um wow i feel i feel like i could talk
to you
for another three or four hours um
because
because we're nerds and nerds getting to
nerd out and it's been a while
and i do miss you and i'm so glad that
you were able to uh to to break off a
little bit of your saturday night
uh to hang out with me anytime i mean
you saw as soon as you sent
well yes please when where i'm here
where do you need me to be
um what are you uh what do you what do
you got that you want to tell people
about what are you
passionate about what are you what do
you have in the world
that uh that you'll or you'll be
bringing to the world shortly
what do you want to plug plug me some
[ __ ] well um you know i did that audio
book
by kweke amazing uh called the death of
vivec odji
and they're really near and dear to me
because getting to do a book that's
um speaking to queer nigerians and
that's
that's not something that i really had
the chance to play with before so that's
out and
getting you know really great reviews
from like new york times and
um npr and all of that it's been getting
a lot of great attention
um also you might have heard that i
wrote and produced something
called in hollywoodland i heard a thing
about a thing yeah bad thing about a
thing so
it's been really exciting we've been on
the uh festival circuit
uh something that i produced along with
karen david from fear the walking dead
and jess jessica sharif uh who also
directed
and we have you know dominic burgess in
it from
i mean everything i say like star trek
and
you know the magicians and he's just an
incredible
actor we have jen richards we have luke
youngblood
and of course karen and i within it um
and we did american black film festival
we did benton
gina davis's fenton festival
and uh just now we're doing catalina
film festival
nice and we just hollywood reporter just
uh spoke to
uh the fact that we'll be in holly
shorts um
so yeah it's been really exciting to
have all of that
and so i'm also doing some more writing
so good for you
oh we'll see some things soon and um
also some animation
so you'll see my name around um but as
you know we'll be doing
a panel for season three of american
girls
yes at new york comic-con right good
yeah did you guys wrap production before
the the nightmare hit yes we did we just
did it was kind of
like all right we're flying you home now
and i'm like really because i kind of
want to stay here
in canada it's cool if you leave my bags
here like
i missed the plane you should have heard
me negotiating mark i was
um but yeah we wrapped good good and so
that's in october early october yeah
um the panel at new york comic con
that's great right and they're like
metaverse i think is what they're
calling their their version of an online
convention
um so yes i i implore and encourage all
of you
to tune in to that panel and if you're
not caught up on american gods you
should catch up on american gods i mean
because
a it's good b what else are you doing
[Laughter]
but making time for good things that is
literally the pitch for everything now
what else yeah where are you going
what are you about um that's awesome
where can people find you on the
interwebs the interwebs is very easy
it's just my name so
on instagram it's your t day y e
t i d e you got in there early you beat
all the other
yati bidakis well here's the thing there
apparently aren't
any others so there's that
um and then you t badaki on twitter
that's y-e-t-i-d-e
nice um again thank you so much for
coming i'm sorry
we didn't have an ad to read um because
i feel like we might have had some fun
with manscaped
what want to hear all about this
can i use manscape i have so many
questions
and there are questions that i you know
may not have answers for
um but uh we didn't have to do an ad
read
um you've plugged all the things you
wanted to plug i'll plug
um these folks who make these t-shirts
for me uh resistance is fertile
um go to embattledclothing.com and if
you use the code mark
15 you'll say 15 of your first order um
it's feeling a bit like this is a time
where resistance
we need it to be fertile because we need
it to
to uh to grow a potential for a better
tomorrow
um and that will only come if we fight
for it so
um everybody fight and if you feel like
buying a t-shirt be my guest um if you
don't that's fine
that's okay it's not keeping lights on
um
but um thank you so much uta
for for coming and hanging out with me
um it means the world
always mark and uh it sounds like after
this we have some
pitch ideas we need to talk about i i
feel like we do
i feel like we do it's time to uh to to
form the the production company that
will
uh take the world by storm uh standard
rich and famous productions
what's that someone's at the door oh
hello
earl disney is that you
[Laughter]
um so that is it for this episode of
black man beyond subbing for fat man
beyond
my name is mark bernardin
um and we will see you next week um uh
when kevin returns from the the great
uh i don't even know what the weather is
i'm sure it's not on fire in new jersey
but
let's say the the the big easy on the
big east coast
um and yeah we'll see you for another
episode of famine beyond i'm mark
bernard
um tune in next week same fat time same
fat channel smodcast.com or
youtube.com kevin smith uh thank you
everybody
good night be well be safe wakanda
forever
bye